when I was growing up actually they had
this dude my dad knew name's sinnamon
Wilson and this guy and thought about
this guy forever when I was a child
cinnamon Wilson was his dude he he would
let us like car like I guess lick a
little bit of cinnamon out of his hand
cuz we didn't always have cinnamon now
you know I'm living in a you know a
different world these days I got
cinnamon at the house but when I was
young we had you know we didn't have as
much cinnamon as we wanted and cinnamon
now kids are screwing around they doing
cinnamon challenges and their hide you
know hiding cinnamon between their you
know their buttocks and stuff like that
and and staring into the Sun and just
doing wild you know unnecessary tricks
but when I was young you didn't get
sentiment all the time yeah you didn't
have as many flavors you had orange
grape
you know peppermint you could get that
anywhere but cinnamon that was a special
flavor and my dad's buddy cinnamon
Wilson brah or mr. Wilson but we called
him cinnamon Wilson he put a little bit
of cinnamon in his hand I guess he would
maybe wet his hand or something me there
you know lick it or cry into it a little
bit and then he would put some cinnamon
in there and he'd hold the cinnamon down
by us while he was talking to my dad he
let us lick it out of his hand and he
was gentle you know he had the big soft
senior-citizen hands you know cuz my dad
at that time my dad was probably 75
years old so all of my dad's friends
were 75 and man if you were licking
cinnamon off of his hand it fell I mean
it almost was like a cake sometimes you
almost wanted to just bite right into
his damn hand meat like it was a coffee
cake or something and he'd be real chill
about it he wasn't a pervert or anything
like that he wasn't you know he wasn't
you know you didn't see his pants you
know expound and in the front or any you
know he wasn't touching your hair trying
to steal a little you know cut part of
your hair off and keep it at his house
or anything wicked he was just he liked
givin things to people I guess and he
was a bird trainer too and he also had
birds all the time so he was used to
feeding
something adi out of his hand so he you
know he sometimes he [ __ ] he'd reach
in his pocket and next thing you know
you got you know you got a mouthful of
all you got a mouthful of birdseed you
know like [ __ ] I thought I was getting
you know some of that tasty sweet powder
that sent him on baby
cuz cinnamon was when I was young
cinnamon was brand new now cinnamon is
old hat now they got all kind of new
stuff kratom and these kids are on our
you know what else
chinko below ball of that you know what
else are kids doing nowadays tangerine
they didn't have that [ __ ] when I was
young when I was young we had more you
know cinnamon was a new something
brand-new so if you saw mr. Wilson he
[ __ ] hit you with that low palm you
know hand down with a little and you'd
go over there and young just get you a
couple of [ __ ] tongue whip so thats
any momoy and then the other kids would
see you getting my brothers and sisters
would see me get it and they want to get
a little head of it so it was pretty fun
i was like a fun game but he was a bird
trainer and he would train birds you
know and he well i guess he didn't train
him really but he would like feed him
and just look at him for a long time you
know but some people call him training
and and he ate a lot of bird eggs too
that's one thing about the man when I
look back on him because he passed now
he's with Christ or whomever he you know
whomever he favors but he did he'd have
all kind of he he I'll say this he was
doing stuff he shouldn't been doing with
the bird eggs because he'll have all
hell of a damn Nightingale omelet like
what the hell is that I don't think I
think you know not supposed to have that
and you go over there and he'd have a
damn duck omelette like what the [ __ ]
cuz I grew up where I'm from you just
have chicken omelets in Vietnam and some
places like that they got you know they
have the balut duck eggs they got all
those fear factor snacks and stuff like
that that fear factor breakfast buffet
people out there drinkin buggin you know
core
and quarts of renacer simin but I don't
do we went drinking big animal semen in
our area when I was growing up we had
regular [ __ ] but he would have that's
one thing in hindsight he shouldn't have
been doing probably some of those birds
is harvesting their eggs and making you
know unique or extracurricular style
omelets
because you'd see that dude he'd be
having a [ __ ] you know tomato with
sparrow omelet like what the [ __ ] is
that
he's over there really harvesting did
you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed it if he was watching
on a TCL TV TCL is America's fastest
growing TV brand it's so fast it's the
Carl Lewis of television brands it's
that Florence Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com